the owners also have approved a proposal
to incentivize the development of
minority coaches and executives that's a
story peter king had over the weekend
and it's very simple there's no reward
for hiring
a minority coach or general manager at
one point earlier this year there was a
proposal
the teams would be rewarded with
compensatory draft picks for making
those hires there was great pushback
and rightfully so because why do you
reward someone as tony dungy said for
doing the right thing
the reward now comes for developing the
candidate
who becomes a head coach or a general
manager
and if you have an eric the enemy for
example who becomes the head coach of a
team like the texans next year
the chiefs get the way it was proposed
two third round compensatory picks won
this year
one the next year if the coach or
executive worked for you
for at least two years i have no problem
with this because
everything the nfl has tried to increase
diversity
in the ranks of coaches and executives
hasn't worked
so the incentive here is to have a
robust and inclusive pipeline
that will then allow minority candidates
the same opportunity and we get away
from the who you know
and who you're related to to create
these chances
and you create the incentive to to break
from this mold
where we see it all the time who do
coaches hire they hire people they know
the higher people they're related to
they hire people related to a friend of
theirs who's coaching another team so
it's not direct nepotism but it's
indirect nepotism it happens all the
time
so this is i think an effort to to shake
away from that a little bit
and see if it works and and it can't it
can't hurt sharing they may as well give
it a try
yeah i actually like it mike and the
only negative i see of course
is a team in the same division say the
broncos are looking for a head coach
they may go
nah we're not going to hire eric the
enemy because we don't want the chiefs
to get two extra third round picks
that's the last thing we want to see
is them get extra picks but otherwise i
really really like this
and i do think it will help uh with
minority hirings not only at the gm
level where there's only two
not only at the head coaching level
where there's only four not counting the
two interim guys
but a coordinator positions assistant
positions because you
want to groom those guys to come up so
you do get those draft picks so
three of the last 20 head coach hirings
mike not counting the interim
jobs have have not gone to mine have
only gone to minorities so three of the
last 20 that's just not enough and
something needs to be done
for more that i think this helps i think
it does incent
incentivize those lower level positions
because you want to groom them to come
up
there's always the potential for
unintended consequences
but i think in this case who cares let's
just give it a try and see if it works
and if it gets to the point where
it's working and we see greater
representation
of minority coaches and general managers
then then you can you can end that
practice you can go back to the way it
always was
because the teams will have gotten away
from
this this time-honored
tradition and and you know you rarely
hear people
criticize coaches for engaging in
blatant nepotism and i think one of the
problems is
ownership always does it because it's a
family-run business in many cases who
are you going to give it to what are you
going to do when you die
just tell your family oh well we don't
want any nepotism so go sell the team
instead of one of you running it
and i think it becomes potentially
hypocritical for
let's say robert kraft to tell bill
belichick you can't hire your kid
when jonathan craft is working elbow to
elbow with robert craft to run the team
i think that's part of it i also know
from talking to coaches that it's it's a
way to make
up for all those years of not being
around kid grows up
kid comes to work for you and you are
together
an intensely crazy amount of time
after 18 years of dad never being around
and i think that's part of it too so
look i'm not saying it's right or wrong
it's just the way it is
but this new approach could break away
from that
and create more opportunities because i
think what is wrong about it
if you are getting people who are
getting jobs based on who they know and
who they're related to you're not
getting the best people in those jobs
and then the best people aren't
percolating
to the top of the profession whether
it's as a head coach or a gm sharing
absolutely mike and you look at the job
that raheem morris has done in atlanta
and i sure hope that the falcons give
him a chance to get the head coaching
job give him a second chance he
obviously was a head coach in
tampa bay for a while but he's done a
fantastic job there and you look at the
minority coaches now
ron rivera mike tom they're doing great
jobs i know we're going to talk about
anthony lynn a little bit later
who's had a rough season but these
minority coaches are doing great jobs
you see the job that eric the enemy is
doing in kansas city and you hope he's
the next
to get the chance he should have gotten
a chance if not this year
last year the last couple years he
should have gotten a chance and he
hasn't gotten that yet and i hope
somebody does give him a chance this
offseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports